Library of Congress
Americas Award
SPEAKER: I'm delighted to
welcome you
all to the 25th Americas Award.
Let's hear a hand for the
anniversary for the Americas
Award.  Very exciting.
[Applause]
We want to welcome all of you
joining us via live stream as
well.  We're happy to be live
streaming the program.  I only
have a couple of housekeeping
items for you.  If you could
please turn off or silence your
cell phones for the duration of
this program, we would greatly
appreciate it.  And we want to
let you know that we have a
Hispanic division have a mailing
list.  If any of you are
interested in finding out more
about our programs and
our projects, please sign our
sign-in sheet.
We are very excited for the
anniversary
and it's my honor to introduce
the
deputy Librarian of Congress,
Mark Sweeny.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: Thank you.
And everyone, welcome here to
the Library of Congress.
I'm delighted to welcome you on
behalf of Dr. Hayden, the
Librarian of Congress to this
year's Americas Award Ceremony.
For 25 years the consortium of
Consortium of Latin America
Studies
Programs, Tulane's university
Center for Latin America Studies
and Vanderbilt
University for Latin American
studies have collaborated with
the Library of Congress to
celebrate children's books that
portray Latin America, the
Caribbean and Latinos in the
United States.  I'm aware there
are many here that have been
involved in coordinating this
event and I want to welcome
Denise
Walter Vargas and her colleagues
here to the library.
But I would also like to take
this
opportunity to extend a very
special thanks to Georgeette
Dorne.
Having worked at the Library of
Congress for 55 years and having
served as the chief of the
Hispanic Division with
great distinction
since 1994, Georgette is
retiring next month.  She began
her career at the Library of
Congress in 1962 moving to the
Hispanic Division in 1969.
In her role as chief she
initiated the digitization of
the handbook of Latin America
studies and creation of the
online website and the
digitization of the archive
Hispanic literature on tape.
As well as making the
collections freely
available online, Georgette
influenced those using or
interested in using these
resources.
Additionally, through her
administration
of the huntington Society Gift
Fund, Georgette awarded
internships to
hundreds of graduate and
undergraduate students to work
in the Hispanic Division.  Many
interns are members of the
current generation of Latin
America bibographers in the
United States.
Georgette's vision and passion
for literature, scholarship and
programming
have left an indelible mark on
our institution and have
strengthened the
myriad of roles that the
Hispanic culture plays in the
library collection, outreach
efforts and programming.
Indeed the tradition of hosting
this particular event here at
the library
materialized in many ways thanks
to Georgette's belief in the
value of the Americas Award.
We wish her a wonderful
retirement and we thank her for
her countless contributions
throughout her career.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: I would like to close
by congratulating all of those
involved in the Americas Award,
the organizers, winners, past
and present, and congratulate
you on your 25th anniversary.
All of you are here and those
watching online, enjoy this
afternoon's program,
and I will pass it to the
esteemed Georgette.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: I'm very glad that my
last official function is
hosting the Americas Award.
It began 25 years ago with the
University of Wisconsin at
Madison -- I'm sorry, in
Milwaukee.  And now Tulane and
Vanderbilt.
So welcome, this year's
awardees.  I'm pleased to
welcome everybody here.  Thank
you.
SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
I would like to say thank you to
Catalina Gomez, Mark Sweeny,
Georgette,
of course, good afternoon and
welcome to the 2018 Americas
Award.
On behalf of Vanderbilt
University and
Tulane University, we welcome
you to the 25th ceremony of
these awards.  We are excited to
be here.
Sharing the ceremony with you
across the country, streaming
with fans across
the country with our members,
it's great addition this year to
be streaming and engaging with
the awards with communities
across the country.
Cosponsors of this year's award
are working with teachers to
develop curriculum that
correspond with books forming
book clubs, creating book
trailers and much more.
The awards are administered by
the Consortium of Latin American
Studies Programs and coordinated
by Tulane and Vanderbilt.
Generous support is also
provided by Florida
International University,
Stanford University, the Ohio
State
University, UNC consortium in
Latin America studies,
University of Florida,
University of New Mexico,
University of
Texas at Austin, University of
Utah, and the University of
Wisconsin Milwaukee, a lot of
support from senators across the
country.
Awards are given up to two weeks
each
year and selected for
distinctive literary quality,
exceptional integration of text,
illustration and design and
potential for classroom use.
The goal of this award is to
link the Americas to reach
beyond geographic
borders focusing instead on
cultural heritages within the
hemisphere.
I would like to take a moment to
say thank you to our committee.
Many of our committee members
are here with us today.
This year's Americas Award
review committee was comprised
of teachers, librarians, faculty
and community activists from
Tennessee, Texas, Illinois,
North Carolina, and Wisconsin.
This year Paula Mason was our
chair of the committee.
She's a librarian for the
Waukesha Public Library in
Wisconsin.
Just to give an idea of the
process the committee goes
through, in the fall books
arrive, throughout the year.  By
January we have our list.
We set up Skype calls in the
spring
and chat for hours over weekends
about
amazing books, and they are
spirited conversations about the
cultures of Latin America and
the Caribbean.  Colleen and I
are grateful for the hard work
of the committee and care they
put into this year's award
winners, Honorable Mention and
Commended Titles.
I would like to share some
messages about our founder of
the Americas Award, Julie.
The Americas Award began as an
idea 25 years ago by my
colleague, Julie.
She is the associate director
for center of Latin America
studies at University Wisconsin
Milwaukee.
She started the award with no
other award recognizing Latin
America and Latino culture in
children's and young adults
literature yet existed.
Her idea became one of the most
important projects of CLASP.  It
has enabled scholars of Latin
America to come together and
engage with children's
literature in many diverse ways.
It has become our passion and
our responsibility to educators
to read and share authentic and
engaging literature for the K12
classroom.  I want to thank
Julie by presenting to
her a symbol she once created
years ago,
a weaving from Guatemala that
represents the weaving of
stories and voices of the
Americas.
I would like to invite my
daughter to share our token of
thanks.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: I want to thank you for
say muchos gracias.  Julia, come
on up.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
Wow! 25 years.
In his 1990 acceptance speech at
the
Library of Congress for the
Americas
Award, author Francisco herm
said for
most of my school days I didn't
find the literature the
experiences I had gone through,
so I decide it was very
important to promote in any way
possible ethnic American
literature and also to
contribute to that body of
literature.  And I thought it
was important to do that because
the curriculum, what we study in
school, reflects who we are as a
people.
So if we did not see ourselves
as students, if we do not see
ourselves reflected in the
curriculum, in the literature,
in the music, in the art
that we study, then we do not
arrive at good understanding of
who we are personally and who we
are as a nation.
From the start, our goals for
the Americas Award were simple,
to highlight books that allow
children and young adults to see
themselves in the literature, to
encourage U.S.
publication of such books, to
showcase
the diversity of Latin America,
the
Caribbean and other of America's
communities in the hemisphere.
And to encourage young people to
read engaging stories about life
in cultures perhaps different to
them.
The Americas Award was inspired
by the
children's Africana book award
created with the outreach
council of the African studies
association.
The book award concept seemed a
perfect project to propose to
the class
teaching and outreach committee.
I had some background that made
me
really interested in
internationalism in children's
book and the committee at the
time was extremely receptive to
the
idea, and we did an event
through my
center, 1991 called "Reading
Latin America."  Both Columbia
teachers college and in
Milwaukee, which I sort of count
that as a starting point,
because it gave us a sense of
what was out there at the time
in terms of this kind of content
in children's books.
The class committee helped shape
the award criterion and in doing
so we decided to focus on the
multicultural international
dynamic, including the Latin X
experience in the U.S. and
including all the Americas, not
just Spanish-speaking countries
and communities.
We also determine the award
should be more than recognition
of winners but
rather should include an notated
annual bibliography of dmended
titles to be a
glide for classroom classroom
use and library development.
As we define the award with
rationale and criteria and what
to include and where to draw
lines, I remember the
comment by Linda Miller, a
outreach coordinator at the
University of Florida.
She said, "when the world is
made up of lumber and splinters,
that is, people who think about
commonalities and connections
and those who think about
difference and separation.
Shaping the early Americas
Award, we
aim to be lumpers through and
through."
The award was further refined
through
the expertise, thoughtfulness of
the national review committee
members.  All of you and your
predecessors.
And as it has matured other
children's
book awards were established.
Each award makes a contribution
and we've dovetailed with each,
I think, in a way that benefits
the field of children's
literature.
In the case of the Americas,
both the awards recognition of
the diversity Americas and
inclusion of a criterion focused
specifically on potential
classroom use helps make its
contributions unique.
So, I remember after the first
competition... Ron, I think we
had a whole six books
on the commended list, and wrote
a letter to the committee.
I believe there was onion-skin
paper involved -- it was back
then -- and it said something
about "we'll look back 20 years
from now and look at what we
started.
"  Well, it's been 25 years and
there's
been over 400 titles recognized
since
1993 as winner, honor and
commended
books, and the ongoing
relationship with the Library of
Congress has given us a
way to truly celebrate the
books' authors and illustrators.
Creatively coordinated since
2011 by Vanderbilt and Tulane,
the Americas Award is stronger
and more vibrant than ever.
And it's enhanced by the
innovative
outreach programming by
colleagues at Latin America
studies centers across the U.S.
Diversity in children's
literature has
a long way to go, but we cannot
appreciate the award, 25-year
and counting contribution to
diversity in
recognition of books of
distinctive literary quality,
contextualization, noteworthy of
text, illustration and design,
and potential for classroom use.
Thank you.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: I do want to go back
very
briefly to -- back to Georgette
Dorn.
The relationship of the Library
of
Congress has been really
valuable for the Americas Award
and it was you and I and a
meeting in New Orleans, getting
in a car after a committee
meeting, going
to lunch, and Georgette said,
"We should have this at the
Library of Congress..
"  I said, "uh-huh, that would
be swell.
"  It was because of Georgette
and the division over the years
that we have been able to give
this kind of weight, this kind
of value to the Americas Award.
And it's very much Georgette and
the Hispanic Division.  Thank
you, Georgette, very much.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: I believe the Americas
Award, finally for you, after
all these years.
If anybody has helped with the
weaving
of stories, it's Georgette Dorn.
Thank you, Georgette.
SPEAKER: [ off microphone ]
[Applause]
SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
My name is Connie Sharp and I'm
a district librarian for Metro
public schools in Nashville,
Tennessee.
I am honored to serve as a
review committee member and I'm
thrilled to be with you today.
I would like to recognize the
2018 Americas Award Commended
Title.
Several English Spanish
bilingual picture books made our
commended list.
One is The Little Doctor written
by want Gerra.
In this story a young boy dreams
of becoming a doctor.
This delightful book is based on
the writer's childhood
experience, and it is
my pleasure to welcome this
author, Dr.
Want Gerra, his wife Tammy and
their sons to our ceremony
today.
We are pleased to welcome you.
[Applause]
We are pleased to welcome you
and inspired by your story.
In Song for
Freedom we learn of Josè Marti
and tireless efforts speaking
out for Cuba's independence from
Spain as well as the love he
shared for his two countries.
Another biographical piece is
Ruben Dario.
In this poetic piece, readers
learn the
story of Nicaragua poet.
Little Skeleton's Count down to
Midnight captures the spirit.
The author engages readers of
all ages
in the countdown through rhyme
and enticing illustration.
Young people's poet laureate and
former
Americas Award winner author,
mar
captures us in Bravo!.
Margarita is recognized today
for having
a second title on our commended
list.  "Forest World.
"  In this timely novel written
in verse she introduces us to
the story of two siblings, one
in the United States and
one in Cuba, who were unaware of
the other until they are
reunited to spend a summer
together in Cuba.
Family Stands is one of several
Commended Titles.
In the "The Epic Fail of Arturo
Zamora," he gets off to a
typical start until things go
awry.
The author tells an intriguing
story
that will have you rooting for
Arturo, not only in efforts to
save the family business was
community identity as well.
Keeping with the theme of
family, the
inexplicable logic of my life
written by Benjamin science.
Tells the story of a 17-year-old
boy raised by a gay Mexican
father.
It is is a story of resiliency,
what makes a family and the
connections that bind us.
In the first rule of punk, Celia
Perez
introduces to Louisa.  After
moving to Chicago from
California, Malu must deal with
familiar changes of being in a
new kid in town and embracing
her punk identity.  We see a
young girl become the hero of
her own story in a book by
Cynthia Garza.
This delightful book offers a
cultural
view of Mexican superheroes and
celebrates the courage and
determination of girls all over
the world.
Award winning author, Monica
Brown
brought us the biography of
Frida,
illustrated by John Para, this
is the
unique perspective of her
beloved pet.
In "Disappeared," two teen ijers
are drawn into the world of drug
trafficking, kidnapping,
corruption and violence.
Our last Commended Title this
year is
Sing Don't Cry by Angela
Dominguez, a loving tribute to
her grandfather, successful
musician.
Please give a round of applause
for the 2018 Americas Award
Commended Titles.
[Applause]
Now I have the pleasure of
sharing the 2018 Americas Award
Honorable Mention titles.
Our first book "All the way to
Havana," my margarita is the
story of a boy traveling to Cuba
in their old blue car.
Along the way they experience
sights
and sounds of the street, the
caring put-putting and bumping
along the way.  This engaging
story celebrates the spirit of a
young boy's family as well as
that of the Cuban people they
greet along the way.
Margarita Engle's masterful you
of onomatopoeia onomatopoeia
with the illustrations make this
an engaging read-aloud for the
young reader.
Second book "Lucky Broken Girl"
is based on the story of Ruth
Behar.
Having immigrated to New York in
the
1960s, five-grader, Ruthie, a
Cuban Jewish girl feels she's
finally starting to fit in.
School is going well and she's
the neighborhood hop Scotch
queen.
Tragically, Ruthie is involved
in a horrific car accident that
nearly cost her life.
She is so badly injured she is
forced
to lie in bed in a body cast
immobilized for nearly a year.
This story allows us to witness
struggles and successes that
form the diverse friendships
that bring hope, healing and
happiness back into her life.
Please join in congratulating
the 2018 Honorable Mention
titles, their authors and
illustrators.
Thank you.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
I'm Emily Chavez and I'm the
associate director in the center
for multicultural affairs at
duke University and I'm here
also on behalf of the UNC duke
con sorttion in Latin America
and Caribbean studies.
It is my great pleasure to
present the
2W-78 Americas Award to Duncan
Tonatiuh
for his children's book "Danza!
," Amailia Hernandez for "El
Ballet Folklorico de Mexico."
You may no Mr. Tonatiuh is an
author and illustrators whose
work has been recognized several
times.
In addition to the award we
present today, Mr. Tonatiuh was
a 2015 Americas Award
winner for his book Separate is
Never
Equal and won Honorable Mention
in 2014 and 2016 in addition to
having multiple books on our
Commended Titles list.
I would like to thank Mr.
Tonatiuh for his many
contributions to Latin America
children's literature.
"Danza!" documents an important
part of Latin America and
performing arts history.
It is story of a life work to
create a dance company that
brought to life the
history and indigenous
identities and cultures of
Mexico through contemporary
movement.
Hernandez's dance and
choreography in
many ways was about recognizing
and honoring Mexico's history
and in turn Mr. Tonatiuh does
the same in telling the story of
Hernandez's lifelong devotion to
her craft and the impact it made
on Mexico and the world.
In his typical Mixtec inspired
style with creative textures and
rich colors, Mr. Tonatiuh draws
readers into the pages.
This book is the first of its
kind to
tell the story of Amailia
Hernandez to a children's
audience and makes more
accessible Latin America pioneer
in the arts.
I imagine young Latina dancers
and any young dancer reading
this story with pleasure
empowered with the knowledge of
who came before them, who paved
the way.
I would like to now present
Duncan
Tonatiuh with the 2018 Americas
Award for children's and young
adult literature.
[Applause]
DUNCAN TONATIUH: Thank you.  I'm
happy and grateful to be here.
I want to congratulate my fellow
authors and illustrators whose
work is being celebrated,
recognized today.
I'm very thankful to CLASP, to
the committee for celebrating my
work, for
choosing my work, and all the
wonderful books that you're
presenting today.
I think the Americas Award does
a
wonderful job in doing that and
highlighting and creating this
list of
books, this body of work that
celebrates Latin America and
Latinos in the U.S.
I also really appreciate and
feel very grateful to CLASP for
their continuous support that
they have recognized some
of my work in the past, and in
the job they do creating
resources to use the books in
the classroom.  I think that's
something very special and
wonderful that the Americas
Award does, creating different
guides and
different ways, not only
recognizing books but making
them useful to teachers and to
people in the classroom.
I take the opportunity to thank
people at Abrams who made this
book possible,
and I feel very grateful to the
people
there, and the whole team it
took to create a book and I've
been making books with Abrams
now almost ten years and it's
been a wonderful relationship
and I'm happy that they have
supported my
work and helped it be
successful, and I especially
want to thank my editor, Howard
Reeves, who has always been very
thoughtful and has made my work
Bert by his thoughtful and
careful editing, but also for
being a friend and just kind of
looking after me and supporting
my vision and the books that I
want to create.
I want to thank my family, my
wife, for
her love and for her
partnership, for
being a partner in this
adventure, to my
kids, who are just my -- I have
a three-year-old daughter and a
one-year-old son who are just
bringing a lot of joy and
happiness, and I thank them for
that.
And I just want to tell really
briefly how this book came
about, give you sort of the
story behind the book.
My wife, Patty, she's a dancer.
She's classically trained and
she does modern and contemporary
dance and last year she EEG been
doing aerial dance with the hoop
and straps and the trapeze.
And I found a few illustrations
about her dancing, and I like
dancing myself and I like
watching dance, so I made
some images about that, and I so
it's something that I'm
interested in.
But my wife's mother was a
dancer and her grandmother was a
dancer too, and my
wife's mother, my mother-in-law,
she danced with the Ballet
Folklorico de Mexico in the '70s
for a few years.  And it came up
in conversation at some point,
and that gave me the idea of
making a book about Amailia
Hernandez.
So that is sort of on one hand.
On the other hand, another
reason for
doing the book, like I remember
-- I grew up in Mexico and I
remember when I was seven or
eight years old, dressing
up like a charro and dancing,
and it's a common experience for
a kid, especially, I think to
celebrate a special occasion,
like Mother's Day or the end of
the
school year to perform a
folklore dance.
And later on when I was a
teenager, I
came to the United
States, also popular and
importance for occasions when
different kinds of people
celebrate their culture or
celebrate their heritage, and in
the case of
Mexican American people, days
like Cinco de Mayo, it's a way
to show that you're
proud of your roots, do display
your
culture, and so I wanted to do a
book
about dance and especially for
that
dance because I know it's not
only an important experience in
the country
where it comes from, in this
case, Mexico, but also in the
U.S.  And when I heard my
mother-in-law
talking about
Folklorico Ballet, it made sense
to do it about Amailia
Hernandez, a woman who dedicated
her life to learning about the
traditional dances in Mexico and
being able to adapt them to the
theater and
being able to share them on the
world stage.
So, again, I just want to say
thank you.  I'm very grateful.
I'm very happy.
I feel very fortunate for all
the support and for all that the
Americas Award does.
So thank you very much.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
My name is Paula Mason and I'm a
reference librarian at the
Waukesha public library in
Wisconsin.  It's a great honor
to be here with you today.
I have the privilege of
introducing a
truly phenomenal author, Ibi
Zoboi whose title "American
Street" moved our hearts and
spirit immensely this year.
Through ib's confidence and
powerful prose, we have the
chance to meet Fabiola, a
teenager painfully separated
from her mother as they seek a
beautiful future in the United
States with her aunts and
cousins in Detroit.
The story is so many things at
once,
but to name a few, it's a tale
of great bravery, resilience of
spirit and faith, and of culture
and family which help carry us
through times of unimaginable
loss and rebuilding our future
when everything falls apart.  It
also pierces through our hearts
and
minds with the timeliest of
themes, such as immigration,
family separation, and the
senseless tragedy of young lives
lost.
However, at the cross roads of
"American
Street," Ibi never leads the
reader behind without hope.  She
brings us alongside Fabiola and
her ever-evolving journey toward
achieving her own dreams.
Thank you so much for this gift,
Ibi, and it's an honor to have
you here and present you with an
Americas Award.
[Applause]
IBI ZOBOI: Good afternoon,
everyone.  Thank you so much.
This is such a huge honor for
me.
Thank you to the consortium for
Latin America studies programs
and everyone
involved in this award, an award
ceremony.
I would like to thank my
publisher, HarperCollins, bad
win gray imprint and
my
editors of Alloy Entertainment.
I thank my family and all the
writing programs and workshops
that got me here.
I've been writing for 15 years
and
trying to get published.
"American Street" is my debut
novel and I'm thrilled and
honored to see how it's been
honored over the last two years,
the feedback from teachers,
librarians and students, and I'm
just overjoyed by the fact that
young readers are still
discovering this story.
I will share a little bit about
why -- how "American Street"
came to be, why
this sort of story is very
important to
me, and most importantly, I'm
very
grateful that I am honored by an
award
that upholds Latin American
culture.  I aim a Haitian
immigrant.  And Haiti is not a
Spanish-speaking company.
It is a Francophone Caribbean
nation and based on that fact it
kind of stands out on its own.
However, it is a Latin American
country, which I just
discovered.  I never considered
Haiti being part of
this larger conversation of
Spanish-speaking countries or
ever associating it to anything
Latin.
Our history was that of
revolution, of French
colonization and African
cultural retention.  So only
recently did I begin to think
about what it means to be a
Latin
American nation and what it
means to be an Afro Latin X
nation.
My recently published book is
called "Pride," just a light
retelling of the
literary classic and it features
a Haitian-Dominican character.
And as you may or may not know,
Haiti
and Dominican Republic have been
at
odds, historical odds, cultural
odds and, there's a language
barrier as well.
And I was thrilled that
Elizabeth
Acevedo, a Dominican author,
, in a collaboration we realized
we were healing both of our
respective countries.
So being honored for this award
that
has a title "Latin" in it is
also -- it means a lot to me,
because Haiti in
itself can be very isolated from
the
larger Caribbean culture and
within the western hemisphere
itself.
Being dubbed the poorest country
in the western hemisphere, being
one at of
the countries that has the
closest ties
to African culture, and part of
writing
"American Street" was about
retaining
the culture that has been sort
of bastardized in the western
media.
In "American Street," Fabiola
holds on
to her Vodu culture and it meant
a lot
to make that authentic and real
and not
make our traditions and culture
a caricature in this novel.
And when readers and thought
leaders,
teachers and librarians
recognize that,
to me that is sort of a defiance
and a pushback against what the
mainstream has been feeding us
for the last few decades about
my home country.
So, I'm going to share the
author's note from "American
Street," because I only have
written it.
I remember it being a tough
process between my editors and I
to figure out
the hows and why of this story,
so that when readers turn to the
last page, whatever it is that
happens in that last scene in
"American Street," there's an
author's note for readers to
kind of
unpack what has happened and for
readers to understand my
intentions.
One of the things that I really
care
about is being understood, and I
don't
always have authors -- don't
always have the opportunity to
state their intentions in a
book.  And sometimes we have a
certain sort
of insecurity in terms of "did I
get my meaning across"?  Did
readers understand what I was
trying to do?
And sometimes those validations
come from awards like this.
And it also comes from the
committee
who planned those awards and
read other books and put your
work up against
others' and others that are ral
qualified as well, and see its
value.  So, again, I have to say
thank you.
I have to put this down.
So while I did not come to this
country as a 16-year-old,
Fabiola did.  I came to this
country as a four-year-old.
I moved -- the first
neighborhood I moved into in New
York is a neighborhood
called Bushwick, Brooklyn, and
I'll explain a little more about
Bushwick and
what it means to come from such
a beautiful island -- I think
all the Latin Americas are like
that, tropical,
warm, family, love, food, and to
have that American dream and to
come from what is considered a
broken nation by
the western media, and many ways
a
broken city, Detroit is coming
back, and the kind of conflict
that happens in that sort of
exchange.
So the first seeds of "American
Street" were planted when I read
a New York
Times article entitled Last Stop
on the L Train-Detroit.
It was about the far reaching
gentrification progression
towards Detroit, Michigan.
Bushwick is the last stop for
whites and affluent residents
who won't venture too deep into
Brooklyn.
Bushwick was our first home in
America.
I didn't know it then but 1980
Bushwick was described as
resemble a war zone.  While our
house on Hancock Street was
fairly intact, others were
littered with torn mattresses
and old tires.
When I read The New York Times
article, I remember thinking,
how does Detroit compare to
Bushwick I grew up in?
It seems too many parallels and
my own
life as an immigrant and time
lines of Detroit, I could write
a train and tell the story of a
girl like me who found her way
to the other side.
While writing "American Street"
I pulled from my own memories of
living in between cultures.
Experiences and violence that
many girls have endured.
Yet more often than not, these
girls and families leave their
home countries only
to move to other broken and
disenfranchised communities.
I keep thinking about how these
girls negotiate their own values
an culture
with the need to survive and aim
for the American dream.
In the George Zimmerman trial I
recognized a little of myself in
Rachel.
And in the many Haitian team
girls I worked with over the
years.
We fold our immigrant selves
into the
veneer we think is African.  The
result is more jagged than
smooth.
Tension between our inherited
identity
and our newly adapted selves
filters into our relationships
with other girls with the boys
we love and how we
interact with the broken places
around us.  I saw Fabiola and
these girls and that's how the
story was truly born.
I wanted to give Fabiola a
strong
cultural connection to Haiti so
that she spiritually is grounded
when faced with a tough
decision.
Vudu has a complex pantheon and
mythological system like Greek
and Roman mythology.
Through Fabiola's eyes her new
world and people who inhabit it
are just as
complex and magical as her
beloved saints and lives.
She infuses it into everything
that happens to her.  This is
the source of her courage and I
think she is more American
because of it.
This merging of traditions, this
blending of cultures from one
broken place to another.
I remember those rides on the L
train with my mother very well.
Graffiti covered every inch r
inch of I once saw a man steal a
diamond ring right off a woman's
finger.  My mother pulled me
close and prayed under her
breath.
We made it to the other side
just like Fabiola.  But what was
this life?
I don't know what my life would
have been like if I had grown up
in Haiti.  But I know this much
is true... I would not have told
this story.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
SPEAKER: Thank you, Ibi.
I'm Colleen McCoy, co-creator of
the Americas Award.
Thank you to the Library of
Congress, Georgette, Catalina
and the Hispanic
division, founder Americas
Award, Julie, and all the
illustrators and publishers who
submitted to this award.  Thank
you to Consortium of Latin
American Studies Programs and
all of these sponsors.
And thank you to an incredible
review committee, especially the
committee chair, Paula Mason,
the thoughtfulness and
dedication of the award of each
committee member is truly
inspiring.
The Americas Award is not just a
children's book award but also
represents a variety of
resources for teachers and
librarians.
To commemorate the special 25th
anniversary, we have put
together a comprehensive toolkit
for teachers, librarians and
outreach professionals to
use as a guide for engaging with
books recognized by the award.
This toolkit provides classroom
activities, curriculum, ideas
for community events and teacher
workshops,
and many other resources and
will soon be available on the
class website shown in your
program.
We extend our gratitude to the
University of New Mexico for
leading the
special project and work on the
25th anniversary come men rative
poster.
This poster features beautiful
artwork by America's award
winner and we invite you to take
one today.  At this time join us
for a reception and book signing
with this year's winners.
You're welcome to purchase
titles just through these doors
to the back and Ibi and Duncan
will be in the adjacent room.
Thank you all so much for coming
and we'll see you next year!
[Applause]